super serious journalism that everyone  wants to know about yeah this is like  really important top yeah it's our  question we're asking everybody today is  what is the best song to have sex - oh  um overall I mean overall yeah it's a  little Marvin Gaye maybe but um I kind  of love  maybe I love a little Jeff Buckley but  right now I love often by the weekend  just just because of the word often no I  mean I see I mean he's probably the most  sexual deliverer of beautiful lyrics  right now and I appreciate that yeah  yeah well hey thanks for stopping by I  appreciate it or the Macarena or the  Macarena  like I didn't talk to anyone else but I  love BuzzFeed thanks yeah because it's  like they have all kinds of different  posts of like eat your way around  America via burritos or like the  weirdest cats of the world